una cosa che mi manca da morire da fare
sono le fiere del fumetto l'ultima che
ho fatto è stata nel 2014
il comicon di napoli e come è andata beh
sono quasi morto in quel momento mi
ricordo alfredo dei ninja call che mi
prende da la collottola manco fosse un
gatto e mi trascina via da un vortice di
gente che voi non immaginereste mai
quale sono state 20 mila persone c'era
talmente tanta gente che il sindaco per
tutto quel caos che si è creato ha detto
è stata un successo
ed è quel giorno lì che scrissi
quell'ormai famoso post di facebook dove
disse basta non voglio più fare fiere
non voglio più essere trattato come un
sopravvissuto di the walking dead dove
tutti gli zombie hanno le mani
attraverso le recensioni infatti quelle
stato il mio ultimo giorno ufficiale da
ospite in una fiera poi ho fatto
qualcosa di leggero come nel 2015 sono
stato al wondercon di bari perché avrei
dovuto fare uno spettacolo a teatro
quindi sono andato lì a fare un pochino
di palco e nel 2020 ho fatto la fiera di
bologna perché sono andato ad
intervistare sul palco renato pozzetto è
stato uno dei momenti più importanti
della mia vita ed anche il giorno in cui
creiamo il più grande focolaio di covi
della storia dell'umanità quello che mi
manca di più del fare una fiera è
proprio il fare la fiera da pubblico
sono sempre andato al torino comics
andavo tempo fa alla sma un di concreto
con un gran pubblico e voi lo siete non
riescono più a godersi una fiera se non
dietro una transenna e adesso sembra che
me la stia tirando perché c'è tanto
pubblico ma è stato veramente così per
tantissimi anni ed ho deciso di rivivere
quelle stesse identiche emozioni
infiltrando mi alla milano games week
vivo questa è la mazzata
in realtà per voi non vuol dire niente
ma per me per la persona che sono io che
non ha mai fatto una cosa del genere è
gigantesca una cosa è tra l'altro
quest'anno abbiamo venduto il culo devo
ringraziare il nord vpn per aver deciso
di supportare tutto il 2022 di video e
ringraziarli per tutto questo
praticamente
[Musica]
la prima cosa che ho fatto è stato a
trovare l'out ft giusto sarebbe stato
molto facile andare in cosplay quindi
tutto bardato mascherato eccetera
eccetera ma uno sarebbe stato molto
facile 2 non ho mai fatto cosplay in
vita mia tre sono alto un metro e 75
cosa ridete e bastardi quindi ho deciso
di trovare un travestimento che fosse il
più semplice possibile vestirmi nel modo
opposto a come mi vesto di solito c'è il
pan era con cappuccio cappello con
visiera girato al contrario occhiali da
sole la cosa che più mi ha ferito non è
il fatto che io stessi bene vestitosi ma
il fatto che mandando un self di me in
quelle condizioni
a tutte le persone che sapevano
dell'esperimento
la risposta è stata sembri più giovane
pizzi di me per non andare da solo in
caso mi servisse qualsiasi tipo di cosa
mi sono fatto accompagnare la luna
arriviamo in fiera e vedo già un po di
gente intorno a me sale quel brivido del
chissà se funzionerà questa cosa faccio
i controlli per il green pass cammino
lungo tutta la lunga passerella per
arrivare al padiglione e finalmente dopo
sette anni
metto piede come pubblico in una fiera
del fumetto fatto il controllo del green
pass il controllo del metal detector
c'era un po di gente nessuno ne fa
riconoscendo
due tipi di ansietà in quel momento lì
la prima sempre quella che qualcuno
possa all'improvviso di conoscermi la
seconda è è giusto che c'è il covip in
questo periodo neo mio quanta gente io
che ho visto una massimo due persone
alla volta mi ritrovo in una folla a
fare quasi crowdsurfing manco fosse un
concerto dei kiss attratti in base
all'orario era talmente soffocante che
mi trovavo con il mio petto contro lo
zaino di quello davanti schiacciato a
fare passettini piccoli e non vedevo
niente davanti a me cazzo che immondizia
e io personalmente non ho mai avuto un
attacco di panico quindi non ho idea se
mi stesse per arrivare ma qualcosa di
simile però cerco di non farmi prendere
dallo sconforto e mi faccio un giro per
gli stand sai cosa mi manca anche del
fare le ferie le foto infatti ho deciso
di farla nel modo giusto la prima foto
dopo tanti anni nella scatola gigante
delle pop di super sayan gruppo
tuttinfesta la devono prendere la
dobbiamo prendere
non possono mancare le foto con i
cosplay ero fatto la foto con deadpool
ho fatto la foto con un gigantesco
chewbecca ho anche fatto la foto con uno
bewan con la mascherina ma la spada
spenta c'erano un milione di persone che
facevano le live su twitch irl e io
volutamente le andava a cercare e mi
mettevo dietro così spuntava con un
deficiente perché avrei voluto farvi
vedere la mia apparizione ma purtroppo
sono passati più di tre mesi è sparito
tutto mi è rimasto soltanto uno
screenshot pixelato e poi mi sono
ricordato di altre foto che si possono
fare ad una fiera quelle con i content
creator il primo che riesco a beccare e
paolo cannone una delle mie paure per
non farmi riconoscere e quella della
voce perché proprio voi mi dite sempre
che la mia voce è altamente
riconoscibile anche se la modifica
artificialmente quindi abbiamo deciso di
trasformarmi in un fan normale mandare
avanti nulla a chiedergli sentiti puoi
fare la foto col ragazzo facciamo ora io
mi sono dimenticato però che quando
chiedi la foto a qualcuno lui magari
vuole chiacchierare un po con il suo fan
e quindi alla domanda come ti chiami io
gli ho risposto
marco mi chiamo marco maglie lo metto
con una voce così sottile così in
imbarazzo che lui credeva veramente che
fosse in imbarazzo e facendo la foto mi
appoggia una mano al petto e me la
carezza per rilassarmi io non
sopravvivere poi vado subito allo stand
di fredrik ma c'era troppa gente allora
vado quello di sé idonea ma purtroppo
era sul palco tornando indietro nel
primo padiglione becco rapp non so se lo
conoscete prato e uno youtuber che
tratta di cibo io la foto di richiesta
per un motivo ben specifico perché
sapevo che due settimane dopo avremmo
collaborato nel canale di playstation
insieme e io ero lì e lui non lo sapeva
per fare la pena persona la fiera sono
andato davanti ad uno stand pieno di
gente perché stavano tirando i gadget e
quindi per farlo per bene sono dato
anch'io sono nato lì con la mano in alto
per cercare di acchiappare 1 e me ne
passa ve lo faccio vedere in slow motion
1 raso raso alla mano cade a terra luna
lo raccoglie e finalmente anche io sono
un fiero possessore di un adesivo della
monster così lo posso attaccare nella
mia panda del 74 insieme alle corde
e volete sapere il twist chi ha lanciato
il gadget era power quindi giorgio
grazie e poi
vediamo questa persona camminare da sola
in giro tra gli stand che si guardava un
pochino intorno e gli chiedo di fare una
foto anzi luna vada lui e dice ti puoi
fare una foto con il pargolo io vado
stringiamo la mano e facciamola foto
io e adrian insieme all'intervista con
renato pozzetto è stato il momento più
bello della mia vita e ancora adesso lui
non lo sa e tra l'altro se zoomate sulla
foto potete notare un sacchetto di
caramelle
le mani altra cosa che ho sempre fatte
gela tra l'altro adrian è uno che parla
molto con i suoi fan infatti dopo aver
finito di fare la foto mi ferma per
chiedermi come va ma io faccio finta di
niente dico grazie mille a grancia
grande e l'ultimo mio obiettivo della
giornata che sono riuscito a fare era
quella di trovare lo stand con la
gigantografia di un disegno di simone e
l'ho trovato con [ __ ] seduto verso
la fine dell'esperienza camminare stava
diventando un'impresa impossibile perché
lo spazio tra gli stand non so come si
stava diminuendo sempre di più e quindi
45 mila persone dovevano passare in
venti metri per due tutto questo
corridoio che sapeva di sudore calzini
zaini ti plastica tutto e camminando
senza vedere esattamente dove finiamo
nel terzo padiglione della fiera
completamente vuoto vuoto non c'era
niente se non persone stremate sedute
per terra a cercare di recuperare
energie aspetta un attimo
non vorrai mica dirmi che quelli della
fiera hanno aperto un terzo padiglione
per lasciarlo completamente vuoto solo
per aumentare la metratura calpestabile
e vendere più biglietti durante una
pandemia è morta alti vostra stavano
morendo e per non morire soffocati
decidiamo di andare via ma non prima di
passare davanti allo stand della
rovagnati dove ci hanno dato delle
squisite polpette di prosciutto è quello
che sembrava essere una mascherina e ho
detto bravi bello regalare una
mascherina in questo periodo ma non era
una mascherina era un pallone gonfiabile
brandizzato vero bagnato in
un'applicazione
scherzando
[Musica]
e mi sono divertito come un deficiente
fare questa cosa qua non è da me per
niente è stata la cosa che mi ha fatto
uscire più dalla con forgione che io
abbia fatto negli ultimi anni il
travestimento ha funzionato alla grande
tanto che anche lui a ogni tanto non
riusciva a vedermi c'è anche una ripresa
di legge centro di cercarmi lì ero
davanti e l'adrenalina era a mille dopo
per due motivi uno perché sono riuscito
a fare una cosa che non avevo mai fatto
prima e sono riuscito a farla funzionale
e due perché mi ha ricordato quanto mi
mancasse fare fiere sempre da pubblico
ed a contenzioni visto il continuo ad
avere un po di allergia a fumarla
infatti lo faccio uno stand altri
cent'anni ma ci saranno sicuramente
altri modi per incontrarci anzi volevo
ringraziare tutti quelli contro cui ho
sbattuto che magari mi seguono per aver
involontariamente fatto parte di questo
video grazie mille e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo
[Musica]
nel viaggio di ritorno in treno per
connettermi a quei due mega che loro si
ostinano a chiamare wifi e connessione
ad internet
ho preferito utilizzare il nord vpn per
evitare che mi rubassero tutti i dati
tanto lo sapete come funziona un vpn ti
protegge i dati nelle reti pubbliche è
quello che dicono tutti vi permette di
vedere roba dell'estero dall italia la
roba italiana all'estero vi consiglio io
una cosa da guardare il cartone animato
sui rulli trulli tales le avventure dei
trullallero sì esiste e trovate in
descrizione il link con il codice sconto
yotobi